go retail for me has been amazing it's
for our local speak to town and made
them fall in love with shopping again
which of course was at the beginning
what the steering group tried to get
together after a great Council and our
mere decided that we didn't want to
become a statistic and in the rural town
sector we wanted to survive and thrive
so we all got together and have formed a
key steering group to encourage all the
retailer's around us to work together
rather than in competition and some of
the things that we've been doing to make
it a success as uniform hours and we
have free the council has paid for free
Wi-Fi and our CBD and yeah just general
working together having themes and
getting behind some of our local
activities and events that are happening
in town so the formation of go retail
has been amazing for my store in for the
town and we look forward to lots more
sort of happening so go retail we are
encouraging through different media such
as digital to advance the knowledge for
people to shop local and come into town
and optionally shop online but come to
court buy their groceries your clothing
and their other domestic requirements
overall we're encouraging the different
suppliers to get digital presence is
furthered in advance and what they have
and increase their overall presence on
the internet in advance that that
knowledge yet so that people know what
they can get in town overall the go
retail is a win-win for us all well it's
been really great because i don't think
i would have had my webpage up and
running if it hadn't been for the go
retail group i talked about it before
but was was john getting involved and
getting be sorted it's been really
wonderful go retail is now recognised
brand here in in southland and also
right throughout New Zealand it's really
bought the retailer's together and it's
given some confidence with the customers
as well so the customers can there
or the punters can now come into God and
they can know that the shops are going
to be over until a certain time they
also know that if they can't find
something in Gore will try and get it
for them so it's bought the retailer's
together we're really enthusiastic about
it and the gorgeous the council have
been great at rolling it out go retail
has been an absolutely fantastic success
and I'm just so proud of the retailer's
the community the council the way
everybody has got behind it and really
just bought into shopping in gore and
the vibe the energy the enthusiasm is is
out there again the way it used to be
and councils can do this
you